this is starting to derail what you're
talking about here in Parliament this
afternoon it certainly is not helpful uh
of course the face of a first Minister
fighting the Flames of yet another fire
yeah
I don't look really challenging of
course any new leader any new first
Minister doesn't want to have to be
dealing with these challenges but what
I'm focused on is the priorities of the
Scottish people today Hamza Yusuf was
hoping to reset his first major
parliamentary speech overshadowed amid
the arrest of the smp's treasurer this
was calling BT arriving home after being
detained by detectives for 12 hours they
are investigating the party's funding
and finances he was released without
charge there were no signs of police
activity at BT's home while he was in
custody a veteran of the Scottish
independence movement someone who was
treasured her for 16 years
after so long at the helm there was an
internal SMP election in 2020. Colin
Beatty was not related to The Post of
Treasurer however his successor did not
last long he resigned suggesting he did
not have enough information to do the
job properly at that point Colin Beatty
returned to the job the party has never
been in a stronger financial position
than it is right now A leaked video of
Nicholas sturgeon from 2021 in a meeting
of the snp's ruling body around the time
police began investigating 600 000
pounds raised for a second independence
vote
you know just be very careful all of us
about suggestions that there are
problems with apache's finances because
we depend on donors to donate there are
no reasons for people to be concerned
about the party's finances and all of us
need to be careful but not suggesting
that there is
this is a difficult period for a party
so dominant there was a raid at the home
of the former first Minister and her
husband Peter Murrell on the day he was
arrested then released as part of the
probe after three weeks we already have
a lame duck first Minister and a lame
duck government and that's not good for
our country the moment two of difficulty
for those who recently stood for the SMP
top job I'm here in Parliament to talk
about how the first minister is going to
tackle poverty cost living crisis invest
in our public sector and obviously the
parties engulfed in a crisis at the
moment what do you make of the party
itself certainly my focus will be on
delivering for my constituents do you
think that the SNP is at risk of
collapse no I don't
um I think obviously there is there are
clearly concerns right now you know it
would be uh old of me to stand here and
say that everything's fine you know
clearly that's not the case
unease and uncertainty in a political
party enduring what has been described
as its biggest crisis in 30 years Conor
Gillis Sky News Edinburgh